the starting pitcher for the miami
marlins is umberto mejia making his
second career start and again second
time around that he's going to see the
new york mets it's called a two-strike
approach and he does it well
and a line drive caught marlon's had him
played perfectly with that
ship to the right side and the third
baseman brian anderson makes a lunging
play
to take a hit away well the shift is
applied because uh you know what nimble
hit like nine balls this way yesterday
corey oswalti
20 six-year-old right-hander came over
from the taxi squad his first story
since 2018. remember he was called up in
2018 when the mets had some starting
pitching issues
oh god and now he's picked off and
alonso puts the tag on and vr got nabbed
here's the payoff pitch swung on and
missed right three
two two pitch
on the outside corner strike three that
no no no no usually you would think
that's the empire it's sarah brandon
nemo the batter now i'm sure he'll make
mejia work a little bit nemo lined out
his first time
it's hitting the air in a deep right
center field off the bat of nemo back
toward the wall and it's out of here
brandon nemo clubs his fourth home run
of the year and the mets go in front one
nothing in the third brandon just really
been
on the ball lately but it just got hot
we're in there leading today one nothing
jd davis starts the fourth
and he hits this one out to center got
harrison turned around right back to the
wall and it's out of here
jd davis dead central for his fourth
home run of the year
the mets of its solo home runs from nemo
and davis and it's two-nothing new york
tom smith in the chick-swing ground ball
the third his first time up
and he hits this one in the air well to
left field back goes joyce to the
warning track it's over his head and it
hops over the wall for a ground rule
double that'll bring in conforto alonso
will have to stop at third dom smith
just keeps on driving them in his 19th
run batted end of the year and the mets
lead three nothing oh another ball hit
and struck well by dom
as vr foul tips it for strike three and
so corey oswalt has his third strikeout
he's retired nine in a row
matt joyce
lifts one out to right field conforto
going back near the wall and that one's
going to stay in the park off the top of
the wall for joyce
and he'll get to second easily didn't
miss a home run by a whole lot
marlon's offense can't get rolling here
with an out in the fourth like to see
aguilar come through and the guy's
behind him as well i mean
that is a fair ball inside the first
base line rounding third is joyce
on his way to second with an rbi double
jesus aguilar so the marlins come
through and cut into that lead it's now
three to one well there we go
now moves inside and andy shoots one
into right center field aguilar being
waved around throw from right is off the
mark an rbi single for brian anderson
and the marlins are winning a run well
more to outline for pa he continues to
get it done with runners in scoring
position love to see it so much fun to
watch him situational hit
nemo homer his last time up also lined
out to third
that's lace down the line and that's a
fair ball for nemo and he's got himself
another extra base hit dug out of the
corner by sierra nemo's gonna try for
three
and there'll be no relay throw nemo has
tripled for the second straight night
and nemo's red hot nemo on it third here
it comes swinging a miss strike three
into the sixth inning in miami
vendetti felt something it looked like
in his lower back on that last pitch got
some activity out here on the mound for
the marlins well venditti is kind of
pointing to that uh rib cage area on the
right side
he's thrown a couple more just to see
and i don't think don mattingly is going
to let pat make that decision any longer
ahmed rosario's fly down grounded out
that's hit in the air to deep left field
and forget that that ball is out of here
ahmed rosario who needs a walk
he cranks one into the seats in left
field for his second home run of the
year
a rude greeting for nick vincent and the
mets now have a little breathing room
it's four to two and he got all of that
434 feet and a bat flip to boot a lot of
frustration ended without that flip it's
the infield a double play depth with one
out and rosario lines one in the right
center field for a base in that'll bring
in canoe alonzo being waved home as well
he'll score hamilton goes to third
rosario cashes two more with an rbi
single and it's 7-2 new york a three-rbi
night for ahmed rosario rosario runs and
nimble grounds went toward the hole and
it's a through for a base hit that'll
bring in hamilton rosario goes to third
a seeing eye hit for brandon nimmo he's
got his third hit and second rbi of the
night and it's eight to two new york
nice hitting brandon
yeah absolutely
up the middle and what a play by jimenez
still going to be a hit for alvarez but
may have kept cervelli from scoring well
good at bad by alvarez a single and a
steal for sierra back in the fifth 4 44
with runners in scoring position
tapper up the line
throw to first is into the camera well
so cervelli scores
sierra is going to get second base and
alvarez to third that will play well
there's no doubt about it you're also
cutting into the deficit of the vets
giving yourselves an opportunity
frustration makes the problem worse now
eight to three runners on second and
third
and edwin diaz
strikes out the last three men he faces
mets pick up the win eight to three
marlins losing streak moves to four
they've lost seven of nine overall as
the mets take the first two games in
this series